la ministre vous êtes donc avec nous
faut d'abord il y a parfois une petite
confusion il ne s'agit pas de confondre
avec les allocations familiales
il y a les allocations familiales et ya
le complément familial de judiciariser
allocations familiales qui sont versés à
toutes les familles sans plafond de
ressources ne sont absolument pas touché
le complément familial se substitue
comme il est vous l'avez indiqué tout à
l'heure à saint prestation qui est
actuellement versée sous conditions de
ressources
alors maintenant il y aura une seule
prestation ce qui permettra une très
grande simplification d'un montant
unique de 340
alors pourquoi cela marche pour les
familles qui ont l environnement une
trois ans pour celles qui ont trois
enfants et pour celles qui ont deux
enfants rien du tout à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant il y avait un assez grand
éparpillement entre les familles et un
plafond de ressources en général assez
bas et nous avons estimé qu'au fond les
familles qui avaient un enfant de moins
de 3 ans avait des difficultés
particulières des frais particulier du
fait que oubien la mer cesse de
travailler parce qu'elle doit s'occuper
de son enfant est il alors il n'y a
qu'un salaire ou bien si la mère
travaille avec un jeune enfant
il vaut titre à la crèche il n'est pas
encore en maternelle où il est confié à
une nourrice et les frais de garde sont
très élevés alors il y avait
actuellement une allocation de garde
mais qui était converser dans les
conditions très compliquées maintenant
automatiquement dès que la mer un enfant
de moins de 3 ans elle touchera cette
prestation qui assure avec un certain
plafond de ressources mais suffisamment
élevé pour que 70% des familles ou amis
ministres heures
on a dit on commence à dire qu'il s'agit
d'une politique d'assistance pas d'une
véritable politique de la famille voilà
pas tellement envie d'avoir des enfants
et en entendant ce genre de petites
mesures un peu ponctuels
oui alors ce ne sont pas du tout des
mesures ponctuelles elle touche plus de
2 millions de familles et parmi les
familles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation d'avoir un enfant de moins de
3 ans ou trois enfants et plus
ce sont 80 % des familles qui seront
touchés ce n'est donc pas du tout de
l'assistance il n'y a pas moins 4 il
n'ya pas 80% des familles qui relève de
l'assistance
ce qu'on peut dire ce sont simplement
que les familles qui ont les revenus les
plus élevés ne bénéficient pas de ces
pays et je crois que tous les français
trouveront tout à fait équitable que
dans une perspective de réduction des
inégalités
prestations soient réservés selon un
certain montant de la fonte d'un certain
montant de ressources et surtout compte
tenu du fait que sur le plan de la
fiscalité c'est ce qui a été exposé
longuement cet après midi à l'assemblée
les prestations familiales actuellement
ne sont pas imposés et que la fiscalité
profite aux familles les plus aisées
alors justement le tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée tous les bancs de
l'assemblée
opposition et majorité confondues
réclamé le déplafonnement complet
pourquoi est ce que vous n'avez pas pu
accorder parce que l'ensemble des
parlementaires les députés demandent et
le déplafonnement qui coûte une somme
très importante 3 milliards 400 millions
pour qui serait destiné à ces 20 % de
familles les plus favorisés ce qui est
donc une somme très importante et
demandait qu'en contrepartie les
prestations familiales soit imposé alors
tout d'abord l'imposition ne rapportait
qu'une partie de cette somme environ la
moitié est de toute façon on aurait
abouti à une situation si on n'avait pas
revu les barèmes fiscaux ce qui est très
compliqué très difficile il a donné lieu
à des études minutieuses avant de le
faire on aurait abouti en l'étant à ce
que en définitive ce soient les revenus
moyens qui soit imposée et qui payent
des impôts sur ce complément familial
donc touche - au profit de ces 20 % de
familles dans les classes supérieures
qui aurait touché qui aurait aussi payé
des impôts mais tout de même auquel y
aurait il serait resté une partie de ce
complément familial et sur le plan des
kits et vraiment ça nous paraissait pas
justifié en l'état si on veut faire ce
genre de réforme il faut les étudier
sérieusement longuement faisant des
études très pas si je vous laisse
maintenant car vous devez revenir à
l'assemblée en tournée à l'assemblée
pour parler d'un texte de l'origine du
rpr cette fois de claude labbé sur la
retraite à 60 ans l'instant